nor stardia belongs to a poor family of
baronets even though they are nobles
they are still discriminated against by
the families of the higher class Nora
wakes up in the morning to start off his
first day as a librarian he goes
downstairs and his father gives him the
bad news that his job has already been
taken by some other Noble of a higher
class wondering what he should do next
his sister Alice tells him that you
should join the heroes Academy more
doubts that he will pass the entrance
exam but decides to still give it a shot
while taking a walk Nora meets Emma
brightness the daughter of a baron and
his childhood friend
he tells him that she is excited to
start her job as a librarian with him
but Noor explains the bad news to her
Emma tells him that she has good news
about his Great Sage skill Nora's Great
Sage skill gives him knowledge about
anything in the world if he asks for it
but ends up giving him a terrible
headache
Emma explains that according to what she
found the headache can fade if they kiss
because that's how apparently headaches
go away after kissing Emma Nora uses his
skill to ask the Great Sage about a
dungeon where he can train to get
stronger for the entrance ceremony and
it tells him about a hidden dungeon
nearby nor goes to the dungeon to train
where he finds Olivia's servant an
adventurer who had been trapped Shackled
to the walls there for 200 years on the
second floor Olivia gives Noor her
legendary skills that he can use to get
any skill or modify them for himself or
others and the cost of life points by
using editor and get creative skills she
tells him that he can restore LP by
fulfilling his desires including erotic
activities more goes around the dungeon
to master the skill the next day Noor
goes to attend the entrance exam where
he finds Emma who also decided to join
him
they both team up with Lenore bleuden
accounts daughter to complete the
entrance exam Nora is grateful that he
found someone to team up with since no
one was even willing to talk to him
because of his status
as the entrance exam consists of
bringing rare monsters materials and
decide to split up Nora goes to the
third floor of the dungeon and finds a
dead Reaper he consumes a lot of LP but
manages to defeat the reaper Nora takes
the Reaper's head back which gets them
the highest points in the exam Norris
family celebrates as he got accepted
into the academy until he got a letter
telling him to pay the enrollment fee of
3 000 reels since his family couldn't
afford it nor decides to go and earn it
himself he asks Olivia about what he
should do when she tells him to try
joining The adventurer's Guild Nora
decides to take on the job as an
adventurer he visits the guild where he
meets his receptionist Lola she explains
the guild system to him and hands in a
form to fill out so he can join after
Noor hands in the form Lola notices that
he has written editor and get creative
skills she tells him not to lie as those
were the skills of a previous guild
member Olivia's servant and she had no
successors when nor insists that he
isn't lying Lola takes out a Tom and
tells him to place his hand on it so his
real skills are revealed he puts his
hand on the Tom without any hesitation
Lola is surprised to see that Nora is
actually telling the truth he takes on
the quest of capturing rainbow
grasshoppers Nora goes to the appointed
location and uses his LP to First create
headache Community skill before using
his Sage skill to find out where the
Grasshoppers are the skill works but
just makes his headache bearable while
he is busy catching grasshoppers Emma
shows up mad at him for not telling her
that he is joining the adventurer's
guild
Noah and Emma go back to the guild to
claim the reward Emma after seeing Lola
cling to Noor gets jealous she signs up
as an adventurer as well to keep Lola
away from nowhere after quarreling with
Lola over Noor Emma and Noor take on a
quest to kill a giant rabbit they start
hunting the rabbit when they get
attacked by goblins they barely finish
them off when the rabbit appears despite
Nora's warning Emma tries to take down
the rabbit herself but is too weak to do
any damage they both hide in the forest
where nor at its Emma's skills making
her stronger after nibbling on her ear
quite an effective way if you ask me to
gain LP after getting more power Emma
easily defeats the rabbit both of them
take the rabbit back to the guild to
share the meat with everyone and collect
the reward afternoor has enough money to
pay the enrollment fee everyone
congratulates him for making it into the
academy Emma and Nora go to the academy
to pay their enrollment fee outside the
academy they run into Maria Albert the
Duke's daughter curious to see what kind
of skills she has nor uses his skills to
expect her and is shocked to learn that
she will die by her 16th birthday
because of a curse the next day Nora and
Emma attend their first day of school
seeing so many people with higher status
made nor feel out of place they both
enter their classroom and Nora is
immediately discriminated against for
being a baronet Emma however
instantaneously becomes popular amongst
the boys the only person to reach out to
nor in a friendly manner is Maria making
everyone in the class jealous of him
after a while the students go outside to
attend their first defense class taught
by a former mercenary Elma stongs
everyone is scared of how harsh she is
Elma starts the class by making noor's
step and making him attack her and
demonstrating backstep she then tells
the class that she'll reward them in a
special way if they successfully
complete it by the end of the class this
motivates all the boys but only Nora is
able to successfully do it Eleanor
rewards him by sitting on him quite a
generous reward indeed even though nor
couldn't breathe this made every other
boy in the class envy him for the next
task element makes everyone divide up
into pairs telling them to make a group
with someone they do not know every boy
from the class wanted Maria to group up
with them but she brushed everyone aside
and paired up with Noor because no one
else was left to group with him they
start off the exercise but Maria
suddenly Falls ill and has to leave the
class worrying that she might not have
enough time left nor and Emma go to Lola
to ask if she knows someone who can help
Lola tells them that she has a friend
who can help them Lola goes to a temple
to ask her friend Luna who is an elf who
is a cleric to help nor out she notices
a lot of ill people lined up to get
remedies from Luna Lola means limit in
her room while she's on a break and asks
her to meet Noor meanwhile Noor uses his
skills to see how much it would cost him
to cure Maria and is disappointed to see
that it costs too much LP informs Olivia
about Maria's situation and asks if
there is a way to gain LP quickly
Bolivia tells him about the lucky
lecture skill which boosted his luck to
fall into situation where he can gain
more LP as if his luck already isn't
great in the city Emma and Noor meet
Lola and Luna at a restaurant when Luna
hears that it's Maria who needs help she
tells them that she cannot help them
because she'd already tried not knowing
what she's hiding nor uses his skills to
analyze her he's shocked to learn that
whenever Luna tries to heal anyone she
uses her own life force even though
elves have a long life hers is not
enough to lift Maria's curse he asks
Luna to speak to her privately Nora
tells her that he knows that she is
using her life force to heal others but
she brushes him aside saying that she
likes helping others just like her
mother even though she died from using
her skill too much their conversation
gets interrupted when a building near
them collapses injuring a child after
Luna heals the child she agrees to go
with them and help Maria but Nora can
see from her shaking legs that she is
completely scared
when Lola hears that she has been using
her life force to help others she hugs
her apologizing for not knowing what
she's going through despite being her
best friend
more thinks of an alternative solution
to help them he tells them that he can
eat at Luna's skill to consume her
finances instead of her life force that
way she will only lose money and not her
life trying to help Maria but he doesn't
have enough LP or money for it Luna
suggests that they should participate in
the har and pride event and try to win
it but it scares nor the day before
Maria's 16th birthday amane her
caretaker realizes that Maria's
condition is getting worse the Albert
family was cursed by a monk after they
defeated and slaughtered his entire
tribe after a battle she knew that she
was going to die soon so she decided to
make the most of the time she had and
joined the academy to live her life like
a normal girl meanwhile nor Emma Lola
and Luna quickly make their way over to
the Harem Pride event which is being
held in a Coliseum the people whom they
will be trying to impress are men
wearing masks who have never been in a
relationship the event starts off in a
man with two girls is called on stage
the entire Coliseum is covered with
complete silence before everyone starts
throwing insults their way the group
Retreats with broken hearts one by one
different people go on stage only to
retreat in vain nor gets worried that
maybe their judge's insults will be too
much for the girls to take Emma who was
at first scared to go on stage gets
riled up after Lola pushes her
Emma jumps on the stage once their turn
arrives making everyone in the Coliseum
lose their mind
one by one the girls make their way onto
the stage winning the hearts of everyone
there seeing that he might lose money
the host announces a special surprise
round for them that they easily gain the
approval of the audience winning the
event and immediately being banned from
entering it ever again because everyone
got jealous with enough money in LP nor
and the others quickly make their way
over to Maria's house
at the Albert residence North finds
Amanda sitting outside crying silently
when he asks what happened she tells him
that the doctors can't help Maria
anymore and she's about to die at any
moment now Nora tells her not to worry
as they have a way to cure Maria they
visit Maria in her room where Luna lifts
up her curse everyone rejoices as Maria
has finally gotten her life back Lola
and Emma however start suspecting that
Maria has fallen in love with Nora as
she keeps cleaning to him Luna tells
them both that she herself is interested
in nor making them even more jealous
later Noor visits Olivia again to thank
her for all the help she gave him after
hearing that he had kissed so many girls
Olivia demanded him to kiss her as well
so Noor kissed her on the forehead
everyone receives a huge reward from the
Albert family for lifting Maria's curse
Noor decides to open up a shop that
sells monster martial with his family as
his father drools over the money Nora's
mother tells him not to worry as she
will keep an eye on his father so he
does not blow everything up in a casino
Nora's father has mixed emotions of both
Joy and jealousy that his son is now in
the bread earner for the family Nora
tells him to go out and look for a place
that they can rent out or purchase to
open up a shop he gladly takes on the
job and asks Nora to hire him as well
with everyone given their duties nor
goes to the dungeon to hunt for
materials he asks Olivia for her advice
and she tells him to get floor
teleportation and blinding skill before
heading in deeper Nora quickly adds the
skills to his Arsenal and makes his way
onto the fifth floor he notices that all
the giant monster on the floor have
already been killed before he can react
he notices a giant black lion with a
tulip on its head approaching him Noor
tries to scan his abilities but is
unable to do so he tries to run away
using the teleportation skill but the
lion stops him asking for his help nor
is surprised that he can talk the lion
tells him that his name is Tiger's son
and he wants him to search for his
friend in return he will take Noor to
the 6th floor nor agrees to it Tiger's
son gives Nora a ride and quickly makes
his way through the dungeon to reach the
6th floor he tells Nora that he and his
friend came here 350 years ago but his
friend an elf told him to stay on this
floor while he went ahead
he drops nowhere near the entrance of
the 6-4 telling him that he can't go any
further since he promised varshall his
friend not to go beyond this point nor
enters the sixth floor and is
immediately surrounded by zombies he
makes a run for it and hides in a room
after a while Noor steps outside to see
if the coast has cleared he notices a
soul zombie approaching him that looks
different from the others despite
causing a lot of LP nor gains skills to
convert impact to normal after Marshall
gets his bearings nor tells him about
tigerson Marshall starts to cry as he
had been waiting for 350 years and
hurries back to me in after their
reunion Marshall tells tiger son that he
has to go back to his hometown to his
wife but he cannot come with him as
beasts are not allowed there tigerson
tells him that he understands and
varshall doesn't need to feel guilty as
he stayed here all this time on his own
nor goes back to the fifth four to find
Tiger son who returned there after
varshall left and sees that he is crying
nor consolidates him and invites him to
his home as his friend
tiger son gladly accepts his offer and
agrees to become noor's shops Guardian
at the Academy Nora's class gets
informed about the upcoming exam element
explains to them that they need to bring
back items from rare monsters that they
hunt Emma and Nord decide to bring back
Dragon fangs and head to the guild to
see if there is a commission for one
they enter the guild and see Lola being
held back by Luna was trying to fight
with another receptionist Sarah for
stealing others adventurers she tells
her to stop bribing adventurers with
sexual favors to make it to the top the
ranking but unfortunately Lola has no
proof to back up her claims Sarah tricks
Lola into a competition and tells her
that she won't steal any adventurers
anymore if somehow she makes it to the
top rank this month if she's unable to
do it she'll take any one of Lola's
Adventures thinking she's going to steal
Nora from him Lola asked him to help her
later on Noah and Emma team up with Luna
to go and Hunt an Earth Dragon they find
one in the mountains and purchase gear
to face it additionally Nora adds the
dragon killer skill as well to Aid him
in the fight once they are ready the
three of them head to the mountains to
fight the dragon nor uses his Sage
skills to locate it before they set up a
trap after they dig a hole and line up
with Spears nor goes to wake up the
dragon who is sleeping in a cave the
dragon immediately starts to chase him
but falls into the Trap when Nora leads
him to it Emma and Luna take the
opportunity to quickly attack the dragon
killing it Emma and nor take the fangs
back to the academy and pass the exam
and the dragon body to Lola to increase
your points but is still not enough
desperate to win Lola takes Nora to a
room in hands touch me anywhere coupon
so he can still help her Nora tells her
not to worry as he was going to do it
anyway Noor heads back to the dungeon
and asks Olivia about rare items that he
can get in the dungeon
Olivia teaches him how to combine
attacks before telling him to go to the
seventh floor The Forest of gold nor
enters the seventh floor of the dungeon
and is surprised to see an entire Forest
within it he walks around and finds a
pack of wolves eating their prey not
wanting to draw any attention he quickly
turns back to go in the other direction
when a mysterious girl with green hair
calls him out Nora turns around and is
surprised to see a younger version of
Emma standing right in front of him
the girl immediately surrenders to him
to ask him a favor the girl tells Noah
that she is adriad a great tree of the
forest and she took this form so he can
be comfortable around her and ask him to
call her Dory she tells him that
something has been eating away at the
tree and if he helps to defeat the root
cause she will give the treasure she has
and show him the way to the eighth floor
Nora agrees to assess the situation
before making the decision more goes
with Dory to have a look at the tree and
sees a bronze bee Which is far more
powerful than him eating away the tree
nor is reluctant to fight it since it's
hopeless for him but decides to do what
he can when he notices how much pain
Dory is enduring Nora quickly goes back
to Olivia to ask for her help Olivia is
hesitant since Nora might die trying to
defeat the bee but teaches him the
target's skill when she realizes that he
has already made up his mind back on the
seventh floor Dorian Noor Scout at the
bee's nest and decide to use the Wolves
to soften it up Nora goes back to where
he saw the wolves and attracts their
attention they immediately start to
chase Noor as he makes his way across
the tree he notices that the bee is back
and Dory is lying there unconscious Nora
quickly uses the target skill to make
the wolves attack the bee lowering its
Health before moving in to kill it as
promised Dory rewards nor with two
treasures and shows him the way to the
A4 seeing if she is sad Noor tells her
not to worry as he will come to visit
her back in the city nor gives Lolo one
of the treasures before the final Point
count making her win the competition the
next day nor hands Emma the wind
selection treasure which you got from
Dory she eats it and immediately gets a
surge of power and games new skills Emma
invites Noir to a dance party nor
hesitates to go with her since people of
higher status will be there and he'll
allow hard time there but agrees to go
with her when she says that someone
might kidnap her and do questionable
things to her nor goes back home where
his father gives him the bad news that
people won't sell or let them rent any
building for a shop since they are
pyramids seeing no other way out of this
nor decides to ask Emma for her help at
the party Nora meets with Emma and her
parents Noor notices that Emma is acting
strange but doesn't know why before the
dance began the host born announces that
the two Phantom thieves are after his
precious Jewel with the lamu top
adventurers are here for security
tonight so everyone should enjoy
themselves a Viscount named Mike kemple
asks Emma out on a date but she rejects
him seeing that Noor might be the reason
for his rejection he challenges him to a
dance duel where the winner would take
Emma on a date Nora agrees to it and
just before his turn he creates a
dancing skill that lets him win the
competition
the lights suddenly go out and a woman
in a costume kidnaps Emma while another
man in a mask Tom steals the jewel the
lamu adventurers go after the man while
another Adventurer Layla and nor go
after the woman in fan
Finn tries to split them apart and take
on one at a time but nowhere uses his
water and letting Fusion magic to take
her out while Layla handles fan Tom
appears disguised as the leader of the
adventurers Nora quickly sees past as
disguise but it's too late Tom uses
gravity magic to pin them both to the
ground he tells Nora that he took a
liking to Emma when he saw her in the
streets one day and has decided to take
her as his wife nor gets mad and tries
to fight against the gravity magic while
Tom is distracted from nor Emma who had
just woken up uses a win strike to break
Tom's concentration Nora takes the
opportunity to knock Tom out they return
to the party with the thieves and both
the host and Emma's parents think Noor
and Layla for their help at the Academy
Elna announces that a new transfer
student will be joining them Layla
overlock nor and Emma recognize her
immediately from The Phantom incident
next Elna announces that they will be
going on a trip to Amora Mountain on
their way to the mountain everyone is
excited about the visit to the hot
springs the infamous bass scene is here
all the girls become concerned that the
boys might peek at them while they take
a bath but Emma later their concerns by
saying Noor would not let that happen
increasing pressure on him seeing that
no one is taking it seriously Elma tells
them to keep their guard up as there can
still be monsters around and they can be
attacked at any moment they soon run
into a massive ditch that was recently
dug up Layla tries to get everyone into
a formation but fails when a pixie
appears enchanting everyone the pixie
tells them that Bandits made that ditch
and she knows a shortcut to the springs
everyone relaxes and undoes the
formation completely Enchanted by the
pixie and starts following her into a
cave only nor is reserved about the
situation he scans the Pixies to see
what she's hiding and realizes that she
is leading them into a trap he Mourns
everyone but it's too late since a horde
of lizardmen suddenly attacks them Nora
tries to protect everyone but is
pleasantly surprised to see that
everyone is able to defend themselves
easily they defeat the lizards and head
to the hot springs at the hot springs
the manager tells them that the girls
will be taking a bath first the girls
are concerned but the boys swear not to
peek at them as soon as they leave the
boys take out masks and get ready to
peek at the girls they hand one to know
her as well but he doesn't take it
saying it's wrong
thinking that he is a traitor a start to
chase nor before he could alert the
others Nora tries to get away when he
runs into Elna but they both defeat them
easily one of the boys sureth releases
all his powers to take Elna and nor down
but fails however he was just buying
time
another kid gets up from within his
Fallen comrades and tries to make it to
the bath house Nora uses a lot of LP to
slow him and manages to catch him but he
passes out as a reward for helping them
out Elna lets Nora take a bath with him
but with his eyes covered Luna Emma and
Lola help Noor set up his material shop
nor decided to call the shop stardian's
Rarities going for Tiger son's
suggestion at a family meeting they line
up the shop of various rare materials
that Noor and Dory had collected over
the past few days the shop finally opens
after a while and it is a huge success
many people lined up to browse through
the shop while the kids played with
Tiger's son outside
thinking that it's not him who deserves
the credit for his family's well-being
nor goes to Olivia to thank her he tells
her that he's going to free her Olivia
tells her not to push himself too much
but he is determined he asks the Great
Sage how to free her and it tells him to
go to the 15th floor nor tries to clear
floor 14 by himself but realizes that he
isn't going to be able to do it on his
own so he decides to ask Emma's help
after she agrees to help they both enter
the 14th floor and soon run into Goblins
the Goblins demand them to put down
their weapons and give them food nor
gives them cookies while sneakily adding
poison to them after they defeat the
Goblins they hedge the 15-4 nor is
shocked when he sees a copy of Olivia
made by her death chains standing there
the only way for them to free her was by
defeating the death chains Emma breaks
Olivia's chains to start the fight both
of them try to attack her but she is far
too powerful before she can kill them
Nora escapes with Emma back to the
second floor near Olivia using the
teleportation skill they go and ask
Olivia if she has a weakness that can
help them beat the chain means but she
can't remember and tells him to give up
when Noor asks her reason for helping
him she doesn't respond at all back in
the town Emma tells Noor that she's
going to do some more research before
they try and take Olivia on again Noor
visits the library the next day and
finds out that a cleric with a rare
skill sacrifice gave Olivia trouble 200
years ago Nora realizes that it might be
the only way to fight her he creates
this skill using the majority of his LP
Norris steps outside and is shocked to
see the death chains Olivia waiting for
him at a bridge
she tells him that it's her duty to kill
whoever entered the 15-4 she was
originally going to wait for him but
decided to come out and kill him 200
years ago a little boy asked Olivia to
be his mentor not knowing how to teach
anything or to be dragged down by the
weight of responsibility she refused to
teach him the boy however didn't give up
and kept following her around everywhere
Olivia eventually softened up to the boy
and begins to have conversations with
him in which she casually taught him a
few things a few days later the boy
asked her about iron golems and she told
him their weak point the eye the boy
thanks her for the lesson and leaves as
usual the next day at a bar Olivia
receives the bad news that her
Apprentice died trying to save a child
from an iron golem he had stabbed in the
eye killing it before dying himself
Olivia started to regret her life
choices ever since then and questioned
if things would have been different if
she taught him seriously she recklessly
went into a dungeon and got caught
Olivia would have stayed there for
eternity until Noor showed up one day
who reminded her a lot about that boy
that's why she decided to teach him
everything in hopes that he would make
it out alive meanwhile Norris fighting
Olivia's clone on the bridge he uses his
sacrifice skills to gain enough power to
take her down but is not enough thinking
that he's about to die Emma appears to
help him with Lola Luna and Layla the
four of them tried to take her on but
she easily takes them all out by
modifying their skills the Clone turns
to know her and tries to kill him but
Norm musters up the last of his courage
and use his sacrifice one more time to
gain enough power to land a hit on the
clone's head killing it as soon as Nora
catches his breath he rushes over to the
dungeon to meet Olivia who is waiting
for him outside she gives him a hug
thanking him for saving her life making
Noir cry